hello welcome back to gay sports
coverage of pax 2014 its proud me where
everyone hey hey hey there are me Danny
how are you doing has a microphone dude
hey it's like ruining your day yeah it
really no it's not cooperating at all
fine look wonderful do i yeah thank you
what someone during the ball this is um
this is for my wife okay it's just water
but uh as it far is it is it full of
overcharge oh I got to overcharge maybe
it should be maybe it should be that was
she's greatest Rida Schilling miss
sherry oh those are contractually
obliged no I already I actually I passed
out uh I play DotA all day ah last
lawyer I played like too much dota I
pass no no no generally it was last year
this right here I like played way too
much a too much of dota and I didn't
drink enough water and I actually passed
out and I like split my head open a
computer yes like no no not at my
computer all it happened I knew it was
gonna happen I knew it what were you
standing okay you'd moved away from
playing dota and then you this is great
it's gonna be 15 minutes of branch on
affixes microphone it's gonna be all
that Tim's gonna call my lungs gonna do
it no problem yeah yeah well he's got
he's got the experience you know but
yeah anyway I injured myself so she gave
us to me oh no to keep drinking at a
hydrate okay so try to not move my head
for the rest of the right yeah just stay
right there yeah i'll type looking at
how you enjoy box oh it's awesome we're
showing showing massive chalice for the
first time like on the floor yeah and
it's cool it's like our like tactical
strategy game and always aims about over
covert i plug it i just gotta plug it
tell them to leave at shilla only have
15 minutes yeah that's why I'm here
right we're not talking about like
emergency trip visits are we'll talk
about video games let's talk about
wrestling later let's oh yeah we should
totally talk about that but yeah yeah
it's like yeah we kick started our this
like tactical strategy game it's kind of
like you know it's like it's like taking
like XCOM and Fire Emblem and final
fantasy tactics and kind of mashing them
up and then we've got like the big hook
of the game is that over the course of
the timeline like the game the war takes
place over like about 350 years yeah and
in
the tactical battles take place like
every about every 10 years and in
between those flights like all of your
heroes are going to age and then
eventually they're going to pass away so
what you need to do is like marry them
together so that you start these
bloodlines and then they have kids and
then there's kids grow up to be like
your heroes in the next generation
school it's kinda like a rogue legacy
mix but like forever war ridley i have
never read that now i was pretty cool
but um thanks for dropping a reference
and I don't worry aware of and now it
makes me look like it's upgrade oh yeah
you can see the the excom definitely
yeah I am I've had the idea for a long
time it was actually like based off of
old XCOM oh yeah and I just I just
didn't think that we could really like
pitch it's kind of an idea to a
publisher until but then like you know
the enemy unknown came out like a couple
years ago now suddenly it became it
really it really did like reinvigorate
like kind of reignite this this idea
that I had and uh you know talking with
Tim he was like yeah we should just we
should just kick started did you hear
him woo office amazing I can't move my
head to look at him or else my
microphones gonna fall off yeah so I
don't want to do that Lee but I can
definitely is it him it says I know that
Schaefer I know that anyway that's what
it is I just heard it again did he's
just do it for his own name yet no no
he's uh yeah he usually does just here
for a sound right that's actually yeah
don't tell him I said that though did
you hear that consignment cheer for
broad mirror
pretty good again I'm not gonna look at
them I can't having that it partially
has something new with this microphone
also I can't look at people when they
write you a machine Crockett Madonna it
makes me feel really quick fix oh my god
somebody likes that video an iron
Brigade fanks got that big oh yeah yeah
what was it like how much time did you
spend trying to make sure that nobody
had copy written massive chalice oh you
know that I guess she saw him Portuguese
bored I am I was really nervous about I
didn't have a name for it when I pitched
to Tim and he was the one that came up
with the idea such a it's such a
ridiculous name yet and it's the best I
love it and yeah it's just like I like
that how ridiculous and silly it is and
yeah but nobody had that bicycle message
on theirs is that why you called it that
because you're like there's no possible
way there's no possible way there's a
board game in another country named
massive chalice there's no possible way
so uh hopefully there isn't oui je is no
no we just check I think we check its do
we check yeah we totally check Tim just
gave me though we totally check we
totally check and much more important
things happening a pack stone let's
let's be honest yet the Royal Rumble is
on yes it's on sunday sunday morning ten
am right and early bright and early yeah
I don't know why I I feel like they're
probably worried about it being later
but yeah I cut this promo video yeah
we've got and what I drink John Drake
has made me so angry was Tim okay round
Drake makes me angry was Tim okay what
you representing Double Fine as the
colon destroyer I do you know what I
didn't even talk to him about it did you
know that yeah but um this is really
John Drake like just pushing me to the
edge is it you're gonna see us sunday
you're gonna see a man pushed to the
edge is what happens but who's you who's
your biggest beef with Oh Drake easily
ax yeah yeah nobody else I mean
everyone's got like I do really like
reichert and and gerstmann have like you
know they're bringing the experience to
bringing the experience and I dusted off
my coffee at WrestleMania 2000 I was you
know we were bringing massive Chelsea I
was like so busy trying to prep that
thing and get it ready and whatever I
didn't have a chance to practice I put
it in the I put it in the machine got my
entrance before I played it a little bit
I played a lot of that game in the past
turns out I am terrible
that game how I completely forgot other
play we played last night at about 2am
and down worth it's that I was in he's
like he's not a great video games
probably like an idiot savant at that
game right that's what I have made one
with d-von dudley yeah yeah that's like
I I'm gonna hopefully just put up a good
showing and take Drake out of it that's
really my uh it's not a problem like
that you're like head butting heads now
with one of Sony's most important oh
it's fine you know we're bringing
knowledge we're bringing massive chest
to the xbox one uh I think that's when
we know why yeah exactly I knew I knew
that they were gonna hire Drake and I'm
like yeah screw that guy but oh yeah
scorch the earth yeah I'm excited I'm
excited for that thing it's gonna be
ridiculous what about the rest of pox
you've been here a couple of times I'm
assuming yeah yeah I totally love it
it's awesome because I feel like like
working in game dev you're pretty like
insulated you know it's like you're
you're just working on this thing I mean
massive chalice has been a little bit
different like this is the first like
Kickstarter thing that I've worked on so
it's been really cool working with the
community the whole time but yeah you
saw a little bit like those evolved guys
are sitting here yeah great beards by
them oh yeah I need to start growing
this thing out just like that beard
combo they had on this couch was
ridiculous but um you know those guys
like when when we were working on vert
election it was very similar thing you
go underground and you're just like you
don't get to tell anybody about the game
you're working out and you're working on
for years and you just like you don't
know if it's good or if anybody's gonna
care or whatever but then you bring it
to a show like this and like it's
amazing like you know you're you're
actually exposed to the people that you
know the whole reason why you're doing
it you're actually like making the game
so that you know people can play it and
hopefully enjoy it and stuff and you see
gamers show up and like be really
excited there's so much negativity on
the internet that yeah it's really cool
to like see people face to face and like
interact with them and and whatever and
and this is like so great such a great
boost for me and the guys on the team
like just to show up meet the people
like from the forums in person and stuff
people that have like watching our
streams and they're like all super up on
the game like I barely had to explain it
to some of the people that come up I
want to play it because they've been
just following the development it's
awesome but yeah it's just really cool
to like it that it's really invigorating
yeah it's like a Pollock plans or
something it's yeah it's so awesome
because you just you see them like yeah
like you see them face to face and your
relay talking about it and talking about
what they like about it and getting
their feedback
like directly it's just it's a really
powerful thing it's awesome it's always
a big shot in the arm for from morale
and just like being excited about about
what we're doing let's talk a bit master
Chavez cuz we got Tim on later but WI
apparently works on like a half dozen
video games at one time man so I'm gonna
have like crazy the numbers laughs yeah
all at once so I'd like a bunch of games
to talk to him about so yeah talk for
the folks maybe who don't know who often
haven't been following your sort of put
post Kickstarter videos and whatnot and
yeah just explain to sort of moment to
moment what's happening yeah yeah so um
so this is like the tactical error so
you as the character we kind of present
the whole game as like this first-person
experience where you're this immortal
ruler that's protecting this nation and
there's this kind of mysterious invasion
from this thing called the cadence and
roughly you know every ten years like I
was talking about earlier it can send
its agency and kind of like corrupt the
the various aspects of the nation and
you can dispatch a small group of Heroes
they actually jump into the chalice the
chalice is an actual thing okay jump
into the challenge I was really more the
chalice came into the into these battles
and then you'll command them from like
this top-down tactical view and you'll
try to just like destroy all the enemies
that are on this thing and then in
between in between the tactical battles
you'll be managing the entire nation
from this like really high out you know
twenty thousand foot view of the entire
nation you'll be making a lot of
different decisions they're like which
characters you're going to marry
together they'll be retired from combat
so you can't use them in any of the
tactical battles but they'll be you know
they'll be trying rying that's what it's
referred to as bubbly try cryin yeah
they'll be trying did I ever not hope uh
I mean you know the fate of this whole
nation is kind of depends on them trying
so they pretty they robustly try I would
say it's continuous a lot of trying but
then hopefully they have kids and then
those kids will grow up you also make a
lot of decisions about like what kind of
buildings you're going to build in the
in the regions around the the nation and
then also what kinds of like technology
technology you're going to research so
it's very similar to like to like XCOM
in the you have yeah like we just try to
streamline it a lot you just have like
one research q you're just kind of
researching one thing at a time but each
thing is going to take like you know
many many years
for your for your scholars to like
unlock so yeah it's like you you set up
all of these decisions on the strategy
layer and then you run the timeline and
the days pass by really really fast like
the years passed by passed by pass by
all of your characters are aging over
the course of this and a bunch of them
are gonna like pass away of old age
super depressing it you know what is
kind of depressing part as part of it is
that I've just been like I've been like
thinking about it a lot you know like I
just got married and like something
about having having kids yeah and like
my parents are gonna brian at talk about
trying yeah i know that right then you
go to trade your child in the art of
combat oh absolutely from yeah from your
zero it's gonna be screaming putting the
experience points onto that after that
child i use a crossbow happy second
birthday it's um yeah it's weird because
it is it is a little more depressing
than your average video game just the
subject matter yeah but there's a lot of
like really cool things that come out of
it like babies maybe is a little bit
come out of um and then when your when
your characters pass away like if
they've led like a particularly heroic
life on the battlefield their weapon
will become what we call a relic and
then you can pass that down to any any
members of that same bloodline and then
that weapon kind of persists and it can
be passed down like through the
generations and they'll get more
powerful as you go through the game is
there like specific traits that kind of
go down as well or residual yeah so
that's like it's another aspect of the
game is that we have like this full with
us full genetic system for all the
heroes so under the hood they all have
like a genetic code and that manifests
itself in like various traits that you
can read so like oh like this character
is nearsighted this character has asthma
like okay characters like super strong
this character super quick and so you
can sort of like look when you're making
these marriage decisions you can try to
like like pick characters that have like
really good genetics and kind of like
you know marry them together and then
hopefully they're their children will
get the best or making a eugenic
simulator I know every we do it so
that's I think we don't you uh it looks
like that it looks like that but we
really don't want it to feel that way
and I think the way that we try to get
around that is that most characters are
a mixture of like good and bad thing
okay you very rarely have characters are
like purely purely like just a bag of
all beings and you're like yeah this is
like the übermensch or whatever I can't
believe I just said that thing uh that's
yeah that
good but I'm destroyer was the peak oh
that's right we had that ok we can get
up that but yeah I mean uh and we also
do things like like you know I even
playing a game that doesn't have like
these kind of elements like something
like X comma final fantasy tactics yeah
I tend to get very attached to those
characters so with these like you know
family like with these bloodlines and
these things like there's a lot of other
reasons to care about the character
other than they're just like pure
mechanical stats and traits and genetics
and stuff so hopefully we have
situations where you know you've got the
the great-granddaughter of like one of
the first characters you're playing with
and maybe like you know her stats aren't
that great or like she got some of the
you know she's probably a more a more
shallow end of the gene pool or whatever
but like you're like really invested in
like that bloodline continuing and you
really yeah you're really pulling for
like you really want to see like see
that bloodline continued and you know
she's fighting with like her granddad's
weapons and stuff and so yeah I'm hoping
that it creates situations like that
where it's you're not treating them just
as like like chess pieces you're
actually like really kind of like
emotionally invested in these characters
and you want to see them sort of like
live and continue the bloodline and go
on smashing Brad mirror thank you so
much going on thank you so much or the
rest in packs I'm gonna get back over
there and talk to people yeah you should
come by I should I will I should come by
you're probably sitting here all day no
it's like two hours yeah and I get the
best I will also get to enjoy packs you
combine I'll beat I'm not sure if I'll
be cheering for the colon destroyer
maybe a little bit what why not I got
can you nice you have that I got split
up your people yeah I believe it I've
gotta make sure whoever gets to Navarro
can beat him that's all we want i'm
pretty sure that whoever gets there
tomorrow it's gonna be oh really well
it's beef it's that thing were there
where he's gonna be coming in cold right
okay oh yeah yeah so whoever wins is
gonna go through 29 other people yeah
and then and then they're gonna go again
tomorrow and he's gonna be cold i think
i think they're gonna know might be I
think we're gonna see somebody new take
it home I hope so we'll see tomorrow all
right thank you coming on broad near
everybody thank you
you